we are awaiting the ceremonial first
pitch and the man entering on the golf
cart
is a beloved figure here in boston red
sox land
jerry remy who played second base here
for a lot of years and for even more has
been a part of their broadcast team
missed the season as he's recovering
from lung cancer
and jerry is on his way out to throw out
the ceremonial first pitch and when that
happens a place that already has a lot
of energy alex is going to go uh even
more nuts
but terrific way to open the proceedings
in boston the last time the native aldi
faced the yankees 11 days ago he got
pounded his splitter wasn't good his
slider wasn't good seven runs allowed in
two and two thirds innings he's been
their best pitcher he's an all-star
but tonight matt count the swings and
misses they will tell a story to the
winner the tampa bay rays a team that
won a hundred games this year
for the loser tonight their 20-21 season
comes to an end
crowd on its feet for the first pitch
and rizzo takes a one hopper down to
bobby dalbeck for the first out hit it
hard
but right at the boston first baseman
well that'll bring up aaron judge the
three-time all-star has been right in
the middle of all the yankees success
this year 11th postseason home runs that
he swings pops it into right field and
shallow on comes renfro he's there makes
the catch he's jamming with that one two
quick outs for nathan of aldi well the
last time the yankees were in boston
this guy was one man wrecking crew oh he
got another one
he got another one no it's off the
monster
and stanton who'd put it into the home
run try thinking the same thing i was
is satisfied with a single oh my a game
of inches but in a one game playoff
anything can count
stan thinking is way gone well fenway
park can uh giveth and fenway park and
taketh away
did he check it he did not the appeal
down to third
gallows rung up and a two out single is
left stranded a scoreless start to the
night for native aldi with an era over
six in his last five assignments there
is some optimism that the red sox may be
able to get to him tonight he's been a
tough customer in post seasons past
payoff pitch
lost him on ball four paul is averaging
just over two walks per nine innings
fifth best in the league issues a two
out walk in the first inning xander is
five for 24 with one homer against
garrett cole here's the pitch and he
swings and drives one to center field
and d gagner going back looking up
goodbye home runs ender bogarts two
nothing red sox he hit it about four
rows up into the center field seats a
straight line from home plate out there
santa's third career
post season homer two nothing boston the
sixth home run allowed by garrett cole
at fenway park this year in less than 17
innings
who handles high velocity pretty well oh
there's a drive for the gap in right
center field long run gardner still on
the go off by the bolt pen it hits off
the base of the bullpen wall blue wiki
on his way to second and he's in there
with a pop-up slide in the double
after all this is a right-hand batter
that hit 287 this year and he's in
scoring position with one away here's
kohl's 1-2
struck him out swinging high fastball so
cole struck out the side
rizzo's had some success against nate of
aldi by the way to the tune of five hits
in nine at bats prior to tonight all
five of the hits have come on fastballs
four strikeouts for nate divaldi tonight
and he got rizzo on the timing well done
by evolving a magician out there tonight
bottom of the third red sox leading two
to nothing the top of the order up there
against the yankees ace oh high and deep
out to right field
judge back and watching and it's gone
it's a towering high
fly ball home run that went
435 feet and the red sox leads three to
nothing on a couple of home runs he got
him as a cub in 2015
and he got him as a boston red sox
tonight
and as a cub
in 2015 it was a slider that he hit a
country mile this time is a one-two
fastball up in the zone there he goes
doesn't matter ball four i don't think
anybody preparing for this one
evaluating this one or previewing this
one in any capacity thought that garrett
cole was going to be gone after two plus
and 50 pitches but that's exactly what's
happened tonight another 002 pitch off
speed pitch hit well to center but again
room for [ __ ] as he drifts
toward right field to make the catch and
the yankees go in order in the fourth
baldi's retired seven in a row the
one-two pitch swing and a miss he struck
him out slider
and the inning is over avaldi mows them
down he's got seven punch-outs and he is
rolling halfway home three-nothing red
sox lead the yankees seven strikeouts
he's allowed two singles
starts the sixth having retired the last
ten yankees to face him
and he gets odor on three pitches he
threw a splitter knee-high no argument
from odor
eight strikeouts for avaldi tonight one
gun base is empty for anthony rizzo
rizzo drills one to deep right field but
i think it's gonna go fair for a home
run
anthony rizza rizzo rakes into the right
field seats
it was heading toward the pole and it
straightened out went past the pole for
a home run nobody beats the ritz both
former cubs heroes with big home runs
tonight both playing first base
both leading off on a couple of hops for
bogarts who's got a hurry and judge
beats it out
perhaps a little bit of momentum going
the way of the visitors here in the
sixth inning here comes alex cora he has
ryan brazier up and he's made the move
the first sign of trouble and ivaldi who
was spectacular through five innings
leaves the red sox
leading by a pair stanton hits one to
the monster again and that one's off the
top of the wall
judge streaking around third the throw
to the plane is
in time to get him perfect execution by
the red sox
what a mistake by phil nevin who's done
that before
in this ballpark i can't believe he set
him with one out you understand that
could have made it 3-2 with the tying
run at second and one out that was a big
play and a great throw by bogart
gallo swings hits a pop-up on the left
side devers is under it as he retreats
onto the outfield grass and makes the
catch thank you very much
third baseman no door way off the line
the pitch hit hard toward the right
field corner hooking toward the pole it
is a fair ball played by judge in the
corner bogarts is coming around to the
plate here's the relay he is safe just
beat the throw standing up disease
sprinted across home plate red sox
playing a feisty style of baseball the
faces are loaded with two god for alex
verdugo
greene comes set his pitch line drive
base head over the head of the shortstop
and then a left center field it will
score two the throw goes to second and
verdugo is out
verdugo is out
however before he was out he had a
two-run single
and boston now takes a mighty 6-1 lead
stanton's two for three he's done his
part
pitch is drilled to deep right field
toward the pole and it is gone it's gone
a home run for stanton he had a bullet
fly ball right center field renfro is
there and calling he makes the catch and
the red sox move on
the red sox advance to the american
league division series against tampa bay
and they eliminate the new york yankees
with a 6-2 win
and they're mobbing each other by the
pitchers mound